five years ago you kept topped the polls
in the European elections today they
languish on around three percent of the
vote and they could be wiped out well
joining us now is the party's leader Joe
Patton thank you very much being on the
program this morning so it feels like we
should start with those polls doesn't it
we could have a quick look I think at
one of the latest polls in the
newspapers today ahead of those European
elections you can see there the brick
state party tearing away in top spot you
kept on 3% and if you look at this and
the brexit part here effectively mopping
up and leave vote what's the point of
view Kip well if you believe them Sophie
I'm afraid the Poehler I believe will be
the one on Thursday and if you look at
the events of the last six weeks a month
where we've had real elections with veal
routers I mean we got 8.6 percent in the
Newport West by-election in Wales which
is not one of our natural territories in
the local elections just a couple of
weeks ago we've got 56 percent in Derby
we've got forty percent in Sunderland we
were getting high teens and 20s in other
places standing okay it wasn't sadly and
I feel that a lot of this is designed to
be a kind of false sorry a
self-fulfilling prophecy I don't
actually believe the polls
I think brexit party is being big DUP
because it doesn't represent a real
domestic threat after the European
elections and I think the only poll that
I'm really gonna take notice of is the
one on Thursday and as I'm going around
the country and we've gone round in our
campaign bus for the last couple of
weeks talking to people we're still
picking up enormous supports we go out
and talk to ordinary people so how many
MEP zazz you have lost under your
leadership well it they lost a few
before I came along so if he's enough
air to say that they all went under my
leadership to some of them and some of
them have gone and when course Nigel in
the second term managed to lose 45
percent which didn't really get widely
reported on that's just the way it went
it's still not 16 but we lost some of
them and some of them went quite
amusingly I think went off to Nigel
because they thought that I'd get a
better chance of a top of the list see
under Nigel and he's only actually ended
up psyching two of them with him how
about councillors how many councillors
have lost well we the actual the actual
figures well we lost 67 seas we won
we 131 so we had a 36 net loss so we
wasn't as bad has been reported since
you've become leader you've lost 268
counselors I mean if you look at you
ever think not very good at this
well what's happening last year when we
had our first council election I
inherited a party that was just about to
implode and disappear
there was no local election campaign and
we did lose about 100 Nazis then I
inherited no campaign I walked straight
into a maelstrom of nothing which had
been in I'd inherited since then we
built the party up but almost doubled
the membership we were at loathe 17,000
we're now up to about 30,000 we were
financially bust about to go broke we're
now comfortably off we have an income of
about a million pounds a year
we've got donations coming in so if I
look at it from that point of view
well we're rebuilding a party that
actually nearly disappeared and I think
you're my own I did it with the members
if um if you lose your seats in the
European elections we quit I think if I
lost my seat in London it would be
untenable for me to continue as leader
but I won't make a decision about what
I'm going to do until after the European
elections because I'm getting a lot of
people from within the party
overwhelming saying to me whatever the
result is they want me to continue but I
will base my decision on the outcome of
European elections and how I feel
afterwards I am I just want to put
something to you because I went on the
leave March mmm you know that happened
when on the day that we were specially
the EU and I was really struck by a
mother and daughter who approached me
and they were keen to talk about you
know the fact that they voted leave why
they voted leave but they were also very
keen to tell me that the half of the
March cheering for Tony Robinson did not
represent them as leave voters they were
really keen for me to get that message I
just wonder if you made a miscalculation
by appearing to ally with a small
minority of people who voted leave and
in doing so alienating some of the many
many millions of people who voted to
brexit well our main focus has always
been about leaving the European Union
we've had a policy on that as you well
know for 27 years
I brought Tamir obviously as an advisor
and he was never a member the party and
now he's running against us in the
northwest anyway because I felt that was
the right thing to do
now only time will tell whether that a
decision was the right one or not but
we've still got lots of people
supporting us who don't agree with
everything we say or what everything
I've done
nevertheless the big overriding issue to
them is leaving the European Union I
wonder as well what that mother endorser
would think about one of your lead
candidates Col Benjamin as well well
this is who I just want to you know let
me just some of our viewers won't be
familiar with the school they are he
said about a Labour MP there's been an
awful lot of talk about whether I would
or wouldn't rape Jess Phillips I suppose
with enough pressure I might cave but
let's be honest nobody's got that much
fear I mean it's really upsetting this
is a bad taste joke which I wouldn't
have made a joke I read oh no he has he
has another existence as a commentator
and a comedian on the internet and of
stuff that he does I don't condone now I
said it's a very bad taste joke I rang
him up and made my views very plain to
him and he won't be doing something like
that again but this is one joke in an
entire campaign which is about no he
doesn't it keeps being brought up by the
mainstream media I've answered this on
every question sorry every program might
be non he's done it he was on victoria
derbyshire giving his rationale for why
he said it and i don't really think it's
an important issue compared to the real
issue which is why are we in an election
which shouldn't be being held and really
the fate of the country is at stake
are we going to leave the European Union
or not I mean you mentioned that
victoria derbyshire interview when he
was given that interview just Phillips
and senator tweet and and this is what
she said she said I feel sick watching
Carl Benjamin chuckling along to people
joining in with a language he has given
them about putting a bag on my head and
raping me I mean do you feel a bit sick
I I was I wouldn't make a joke like that
I don't condone it and I don't I don't
think the bag remark was in whatever he
said doesn't make me feel sick when you
look at so I don't either the Internet
is a pretty rough and ready place at the
best of times but I think a lot of
people were sick when she said that
about the 1,400 sexual assaults in
Cologne that it was compared to a night
out in Birmingham I don't think that was
a tasteful remark Iver so she's not
exactly a stranger to controversy she's
not a shrinking violet she's a rough
tough labor MEP
MP shouldn't a servant I wouldn't have
made it I don't condone it she doesn't
deserve it I just you know and I just
want to won because you said you have
been asked about this before and you
often say that you know the reason that
you are reaching out to people like Carl
Benjamin and tell me of Alban centers
because they allow you Kip to reach new
voices they had this internet presence
that allows you to reach new audiences
but partly can't help wondering if they
are not getting more from this
relationship than you are when you're
tanking in the polls they're getting
more from you than that my memberships
going up and what another figure
interesting figure that was told to me
last week is that in the eighteen to
twenty fives we are now second-biggest
to labor in terms of people who in that
age group who intend to vote for us and
approve of what we're doing so it's
actually where you're a second to labor
labor is on about thirty or percent we
were on about fourteen percent and
everyone was a loner I can't remember
the exact who exactly did this polling
but that was the figure I was given okay
I've got a surprise because that doesn't
chime with well that's what I was told
and I said are you sure about that and I
said yes that's what it's saying now if
we're doing that that shows me that we
are meeting out and one thing's been
said to me as well by people around the
country in our branches is that they're
bringing in a lot of younger people now
as branch officers and branch activists
which is great because that means we've
got fresh people coming through to take
us through into the next load of
elections which of course is gonna be a
general election now I think I'd like to
I might get the chance to talk to about
Sophie is any piece that are elected in
this next Parliament what are they going
to do now we you your guests early on
we're talking about the withdrawal
agreement now one thing that the new MEP
S will have to do if the withdrawal
agreement is passed in parliament is
vote on it in the European Parliament
and in fact the existing MEP could be
called back for an emergency plenary in
June in order to vote on him if it's
passed by Parliament now my opinion all
and I've been entirely consistent about
this all through the process is that
what's been cooked up by Parliament I
sorry what's been presented to them by
Mrs May is they're not really leaving
the EU withdrawal agreement so if any UK
penny piece were elected will
vote against that withdrawal agreement
in the European Parliament is the final
step in the article 50 process and we
are not just about rhetoric sign leave
means leave we're actually go going to
put the government-backed or help to put
the government back to square one so
then they have to leave under their own
steam and under a No Deal scenario ok
draw button thank you much for coming on
your walk